late last night we positively identified
the victim as seven-year-old liam
houstead l-i-a-m houstead
h-u-s-t-e-d he is a seven-year-old child
who lives
in san jose california we now finally
know the name of the boy whose body was
found in the desert near mountain
springs nearly two weeks ago
thank you so much for joining us at four
o'clock this afternoon i'm kirsten joyce
and i'm christian coss that is world now
the search is on for his mother we're
talking about samantha moreno rodriguez
she is from san jose california and was
spotted in the las vegas area
a day or so before liam's body was found
the i-team's vanessa murphy joining us
live with more information
vanessa
police say the suspect in this child's
mother is his
own mother they are searching for her
and they are
asking the public for help lieutenant
ray spencer says this is the woman
they're looking for
35 year old samantha moreno rodriguez
they say this is the vehicle she may be
driving a 2007
dark blue dodge which may be packed with
belongings
she was last seen at a denver area hotel
this is her seven-year-old son she's
accused of killing and dumping near a
trail
between las vegas and pahrump liam
husted lieutenant spencer says
he talked with the child's father who is
not a suspect
a short while ago i spoke with the
father about 60 minutes ago before i
came out here
because i didn't want him to see this
press conference without me explaining
what was about to transpire
i will tell you it's a heartbreaking
conversation to have
this has been an emotional last 10 days
for myself
all the investigators that have been
working on it and we're just glad we're
able to get some closure for liam
and then hold the person responsible for
this crime
lieutenant spencer says he's asking
anyone who may recognize the mother they
could have seen her in the las vegas
valley maybe on the 27th or 28th
driving that dark blue vehicle he's also
asking anyone who may work in a hotel
or motel to take a closer look saying
perhaps
she could have checked in now if you
have any information
you should call crime stoppers
leave a 702-385-5555 anonymously so
again just to wrap up
metro police held a press conference a
short while ago
here at headquarters they say they now
know the identity of the child whose
body was found between trump and las
vegas
and they are searching for his mother
both are from the san jose area
reporting live vanessa murphy 8 news now
thank you vanessa we are going to
continue to monitor all of these
developments closely as police search
for the boy's mother
check it anytime for updates on our
website as well 8newsnow.com